I want to call this next clip ironic but
it's so disgusting that maybe I'll call
it tragically ironic Fox News had to
literally interrupt its own
fear-mongering about Hispanic immigrants
at the u.s. border in El Paso Texas to
cut to breaking news that an
anti-immigrant extremist went to the
border in El Paso and shot people
because he believes Hispanic immigrants
are taking over the country the exact
thing that Fox News was fear-mongering
about when they broke into their own
coverage and before we get into this
just to be like crystal clear I know
I've mentioned this this story will be
demonetised by YouTube we will earn no
money on this bundle we consider this
obviously so important that we have to
cover it so please consider supporting
us directly at join pakman.com share the
video like the video comment on the
video that's all really important even
if we don't make any money from this
story let's look at the video FoxNews
spent their entire morning on Saturday
scaring people with the number of
illegals expected to cross all of this
other stuff then a story about drug
smuggling at the border and then right
in the middle of a report here we go
literally going to their reporter who
happens to already be in El Paso to fear
monger about the border and then they go
to a report of the shooting that has
taken place take a look this crisis on
the border likely not going to be over
anytime soon at least from a
congressional standpoint several
Democratic lawmakers told me that there
is almost no chance of Congress tackling
the loopholes in our immigration system
before the next election meaning this
crisis more than a hundred thousand
people crossing the border each of the
last four months now is going to
continue for at least another year and a
half if not more
Jillian Garrett thanks for that we're
gonna know now too
a Fox News Alert we're getting word of
it
situation in El Paso Texas residents
there are being warned to stay clear of
the cell of vyas Vista Mall area with
police officials saying the scene is
still active can it be any more direct
than this Fox News had to briefly
interrupt their fear-mongering over
Hispanic immigrants and quote illegals
to report that someone radicalized by
fear-mongering
about Hispanic immigrants and quote
illegals went to the border and killed
20 people a border town I understand he
wasn't literally at the border in El
Paso which is where a lot of this is
happening and then as I've already told
you went directly back into the
fear-mongering did Fox News about how
video games may actually be the cause we
need to be looking at for this shooting
I actually did something this weekend I
never do my curiosity got the best of me
I turned on Fox News to see their
coverage of the shooting I watched about
20 minutes this was the 20 minutes I
watched were hours after the shooters
right-wing manifesto had been found and
published we knew the right-wing
radicalization and motivation of the
shooter and in those 20 minutes those 20
minutes were all about the shooting that
I watched on Fox News they didn't
mention the ideology or the motivations
of the shooter once they said he had a
manifesto they claimed that they weren't
going to say what was in it in the same
way that they're not going to say the
shooters name and of course these two
things are very different you might have
noticed you maybe didn't I haven't
mentioned any of the shooters names from
this weekend in this entire show but
I've told you plenty about their
political background and their
radicalization and their backgrounds it
is not the same thing it's not
mentioning the name and also I actually
don't know does Fox News not say the
name of Islamic shooters I genuinely
don't know the answer to that so we've
got to stop funding Fox News okay we've
got to cut the cord and support programs
you like a lot of people don't realize
this but when you have a cable TV
subscription a piece of that goes to Fox
News according to a report in variety
Fox News makes a dollar 55 per cable
subscriber okay imagine how many of you
could cut your cable figure out what you
want to watch and get that directly
there are ways to get your news channels
or if you want
content that's on Netflix or Amazon
Prime or whatever the case may be and
put that dollar 55 that you're currently
putting towards FoxNews towards a show
you like it could be the David Pakman
show it could be a different one do the
numbers we have seven hundred and ten
thousand YouTube subscribers we have a
growing following on Twitch we have 200
radio and TV stations imagine if just
10% of our audience cut their cable sent
us a dollar fifty five a month and then
put the rest towards other shows that
they find valuable that they like
imagine how strong independent
progressive media would be if we were to
do that we will take a quick break make
sure you are following me on instagram
at david dot Pakman and follow the show
on twitch at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman if you have Amazon Prime you can
subscribe to us on Twitch with twitch
Prime it costs you nothing it counts as
a paid subscription for us a fantastic
way to support the work that we're doing
today's sponsor is Skillshare and I'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to skill share
when you click the link underneath this
video skill shares the site that offers
over 25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at
than 10 bucks a month get better at
whatever it is that you're passionate
about or discover something brand-new
that you didn't even know that you would
love and join skill shares other 7
million users by clicking the link
underneath this video
[Music]